If you get butterflies every time you see that special someone,...
...learn how to tell them how you feel.
You will need : forethought, inner strength and courage.
Step one : Assess your time together.
Every relationship evolves differently...
...but it's best to wait at least two months before saying the "L" word.
Step two : Think ahead to plan something special such as a night out,...
...dinner at home or ice cream in the park and seize the moment when it feels right.
But don't force it.
Step three : Rely on your inner strength...
...and work up the courage to let the other person know how you feel...
...and be prepared to hear that they might not feel the same way.
Step four : Give the other person time to adjust and think about it...
...and tell them directly to not answer until they are ready.
Be prepared to wait hours or even days for an answer.
Don't rush the other person.
Step five : Beware of using either e-mail or text messages to say "I love you" for the first time.
While they may feel safer, they are too impersonal.
Step six : Be creative when it comes to saying "I love you."
Signs, notes, and other nonverbal cues can work wonderfully if you keep them personal and genuine.
Did you know?
One of the oldest Valentine's Day cards written in English...
...dates back to 1477, over 500 years ago.